are you afraid to leave the house
because you don't want to run into a
woman-hating ex boyfriend cheated on you
with your mother me to this little
exercise I learned on Instagram will
really help you conquer your fears
do one thing everyday that scares you
personally spiders scare the out of
me hope and prostitution already that 1
i'm sick and I'm fine but I've always
been afraid that no one around to
painting for sex
it's time to face my insecurities and
really put myself out there
I like your freckles by the way where
did you get them what is solo going
right now we're having but effective who
had me look
wish me luck boys looking for a cute
eyes
okay well have a good night
you have to remember everyone you meet
is fighting a battle you know nothing
about you can take things personally
Patriot the customers use venmo exciting
her own battle previous environmentally
friendly and hopefully horn uber paint
area where he was missing in action
no I'm looking for Rebecca I can be
whoever you want things where are my
keys
oh I get there go back to my place Myron
is an infection in another fear kills
about Patrick